[Music]
which object is real and which is a
drawing these videos show standard
everyday objects but they're not as real
as they seem Howard Lee challenges his
viewers to spot the difference
testing their preconceptions he wants
people to question reality what makes a
video great is the moment at which it
becomes something you didn't expect it
to be so whether it's that you were
looking at a drawing and you didn't
realize it was a drawing or whether you
were looking at a drawing that then
started moving and becomes an animation
and mixes with reality Lee draws the
object but he also films himself as he's
drawing and he regards in the final
video as the actual work of art and he
often posts the result on Instagram
where he already has almost 175,000
followers it's not elitist in any way it
doesn't require somebody to endorse it
or to put money behind it it doesn't
matter how old you are or how
experienced you are how qualified you
are anybody can put a drawing video
painting and artwork or a video creation
or anything online and it's judged
purely on its own merits
how at least fan base is growing by the
minute and so is this bank account he's
not only selling his prints and drawings
he's also making commercials Howard Lee
used to teach art in New Castle in
northern England but has been devoting
most of his time to making videos since
2015
his learnt a lot of the techniques
online it's been known through other
people demonstrating it in their videos
on Instagram or on YouTube in tutorials
if I need to learn something the first
place I'll go is YouTube to try and find
somebody to teach me how to do it
normally I can he's also trying his hand
at animation live models are starting to
appear in some of his videos all famous
characters from Hollywood films
[Music]
is it real or is it fake
Howard Lee can make you wonder if only
for a second or two
[Music]